we're gonna begin with this Anthony the
news hasn't changed much since you left
it still we're still talking about
coronavirus and new evidence that the
corona virus pandemic is running rampant
in many parts of this country the total
number of cases reported across the US
has reached 3.3 million and that
includes more than 190,000 over the
weekend alone more states and cities are
urging people to wear your mask in
public even president trump
wore one when he visited Walter Reed
Medical Center on Saturday Florida
Florida reported more than 15,000 new
cases yesterday that shatters the
one-day record for any state and
continues a dramatic jump in infections
there nearly 20% of all Kovac tests in
Florida have been positive over the past
seven days our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in
Orlando David this is as bad as we've
seen it yeah Anthony look within the
last 24 hours there were 7500 people
hospitalized with corona virus statewide
that's about 550 more people than we saw
hospitalized on Friday night down in
Miami the ICU czar near capacity not
quite there here in Orange County where
Disneyworld is based by the way the test
positivity rate is nearly 13% now
remember the experts say it should be
near five percent before businesses and
governments reopen but Disney World is
opening anyway they did this weekend and
this is what it looked like that is the
sound of a new normal at Walt Disney
World
mandatory masks and social distancing
which is even being enforced on the rise
to of the resource for Maine Parks Magic
Kingdom and animal kingdom fully open to
guests on Saturday as the state's
coronavirus cases continue to accelerate
cases are also climbing again in
Louisiana where today a statewide order
from Governor John bel Edwards will go
into effect it mandates masks in public
and limits all bars to takeout and
delivery only we have no reason to
believe that the numbers that we've been
reporting over the last few days are
gonna get any better over the next
couple of weeks in fact they they are
likely to get force but the announcement
is frustrating people like Mark Shetler
he's the general manager of Bar Tonique
in the French Quarter and says not all
bars deserve to be shut down we're doing
everything we can to keep the community
safe
over everything to keep our staff safe
for what for a bunch of people on
Bourbon Street or whatever it is who
don't care about the public health to
put us out of business to Texas now
Houston's mayor is calling for a
citywide shutdown as I see use in the
area hit 97 percent capacity the numbers
are continuing to rise we have to
recognize the fact that not everybody is
going to put on this man's
hospitalizations statewide have hit a
record for 14 days straight now the
Department of Defense says it's sending
around 580 medical personnel there to
help and in the state's hard-hit Rio
Grande Valley in the south this funeral
home director says he has been
overwhelmed with requests we do about
maybe 6 to 10 euros a month and
10 a week if you look nationally the
average daily rate of coronavirus deaths
rose nearly 42 percent last week for
weeks officials including the president
have waived off rise in cases pointing
to the low death rate as a reason to
remain calm but listen to what Admiral
Brett geraw
of the White House coronavirus Task
Force said about that yesterday we do
expect deaths to go up if you have more
cases more hospitalizations we do expect
to see that over the next two or three
weeks before this turns around remember
whatever the cases are today the deaths
regarding today's cases may not be
reflected for two to three weeks down
the road listen a lot of people ask
they'll just tell us the positive
numbers tell us the negative numbers too
so the positive cases here in the state
of Florida nearly two hundred and
sixty-nine thousand the negatives 2.3
million but remember yesterday was a
record-setting rate Tony they had more
cases here in the state of Florida in
one day yesterday than any other state
in the country since the pandemic
started yeah and that includes New York
that's what's so worrying about this
outbreak down there David thank you very
much